ourselves craig middlebrooks samantha in
the boardroom miranda in the bedroom i
know it's not ideal but it's who i
am this is my friend madison she's
amazing and she drove me here
okay
look at me yes okay here's what's
happening i want to auction off a
personalized johnny karate song tomorrow
so i need you to come to the auction
ah auction okay yeah let me write that
down in the world
and eagle's got a new queen everybody's
really mean
[Music]
well this is different from what i
expected to find
morning guys good morning leslie what
did you do to the office
ron you're wearing my yoga clothes
you're going to stretch out the elastic
we're sorry
hi i'm donna oh that is the perfect name
for you i love it never change it
wasn't gonna you're craig right oh
yes i hate that name so boring sound
like someone's cousin
craig craig i want to be a spanish man
named terence but that didn't happen
okay so here's my list of duties
i'm basically the office manager how
about you
oh i did everything everything i carried
the eagleton department on my shoulders
for years and i loved every second of it
you don't even know
the news site looks good nice work oh my
god these dogs are so cute
i want to throw up and kill myself
animal control had to take in all the
pets from eagleton
and crazy craig used to run all their
shelters so
he helped me make an adoption website
for all their dogs if you can look at
that site and not want to take home 50
dogs
you're basically a war criminal
see the way that dog is rolling around
in a puddle that's something andy does
when he gets hot
you're right that is so andy oh my god
that dog is totally
tom i don't know why it doesn't look
like him but it just is it's like the
dog is the essence of tom
okay important meeting in the conference
room right now we are going to all pick
our spirit dogs
oh i've got to pick up gayle at the
airport larry i swear to god if you
leave right now we will make your spirit
dog a miniature schnauzer
is that bad yes get in there
hello everyone thank you all for coming
to this wonderful
and calm event our first item up for bid
is to all access vip passes to the unity
concert let's start the bidding at 40.
do i hear 40. thank you 40. we can beat
this
50 anyone for 50 50 thank you sir
terrific
any higher no well that's fine
we're all just calm and happy people
enjoying ourselves together on earth
sold for 50 how magnificent leslie
that's less than face value you need
passion zeal showmanship i don't have
the gavel so i'm powerless i respect the
hierarchy of the auction
donna april wine country train is
leaving the station you ready i want to
come
i love wine and everything about it the
soil the vines i studied botany for
three years at purdue university go
boilermakers give it back
it's okay i'm fine stay relaxed oh my
god there's squat everywhere
call a doctor no color corner it's
disgusting ah
i can't handle all this fighting it's
like thanksgiving 2004
all over again don't even ask somebody
follow me i'm distraught
i guess we can make a switch to bermuda
grass it's only 80 cents more per square
foot
what give me give me give me you want me
to put bermuda grass in a continental
climate that's a six on the beaufort
scale
in a park with zero drainage i want
kentucky bluegrass i want a 10
discount and i want you to apologize to
my best friend donna
yeah hi is there and i'm just guessing
here's some kind of
medication that you maybe need a lot of
and have taken none of or maybe too much
of today oh i have a medical condition
all right it's called caring too much
and it's incurable also i have eczema
oh now remember it's about finding a dog
that captures your spirit
see this is craig
oh no that is insane i will burn this
place to the ground if you pick that one
okay good choice it's new world northern
california napa valley
someplace beautiful and warm and amazing
where everyone is in great shape and the
night
sky is full of stars i sold everything
on the auction list no thanks to you
people
what's so wonderful that you're all
celebrating while i do all the hard work
we're having triplets oh
great first my cousin wynonna gets into
a car accident the night my one-man show
opens and now this
why are my accomplishments always
overshadowed congratulations i suppose
hey that's nice of you yeah yeah i'll
take that yeah big plans tonight craig
you know i have a ton of work to do plus
my dvr is 13 months pregnant with
episodes of scandal
scandal's my favorite show i love every
character
except for mellie oh of course you like
scandal
because you're amazing i love you and no
matter what happens with this job
i will always love you excuse me
who even are you that was so spud on it
was scary
i need to go lie down for 45 minutes no
an hour a full hour
mike patterson is eagleton's most
tenacious reporter when he sinks his
teeth into something he's like a dog
with a bone
oh my god you can't lean into whisper
and then yell that's not fair it's time
andrew these kids are tearing my house
apart and i need you to calm them with
the power of song
oh gosh here's the thing i can't do it i
got laryngitis
you will not bail on me andrew dwyer you
will perform
my nephew was something then outcast in
his school and i got erica sorbene to
come which is a huge
get she rules the first grade and this
party will determine his social status
for the next 100 years
so you better get out there or i am
going to lose that have you not lost it
well you don't even know
i'm going to go home and feel totally
fine
who am i kidding i'm gonna go home and
put on a macy gray album and cry in the
mirror why are you bummed
are you all blind i want that job at
tom's bistro i've been trying to show
you for the last five
hours look man you know your stuff but
you're like a crazy volcano
you have to show me you can bring it
down a notch i'll bring it down a
thousand notches if i have to
may i assist you with a wine tonight
yeah i'm having fish so
maybe a full-bodied red
you know sir you might want to consider
something white to go with your fish
no red and bring some ice cubes i like
ice cubes in my red wine
i'll have a glass of your most expensive
red wine mixed with a glass of your
cheapest white wine served in a dog bowl
silly straws all around please i'll be
right back with my recommendations
seems to be keeping it together what
kind of monster orders red with fish
i i know they're messing with me and
it's just a test but have some decency
for you sir a light crispino with just a
hint of lemon to bring out the flavors
in your fish
i brought you a bowl cabernet which
should still taste okay when watered
down
and for you madam uh would you consider
this rose it's halfway between red and
white
thanks very much enjoy
think i may have found my new sommelier
that was so embarrassing
we'll have to make sure the wine cellar
tom's bistro is soundproof
okay focus up you little monsters not
you erica you're an angel and we're
thrilled you're here
now a soft opening tomorrow from now on
everyone call me kristen because i am
wigging out right now
ugh the sawdust from ron's chairs is
everywhere my sinuses are on the fritz
and smell us ninety percent of taste
maybe 95.
okay craig donna's gonna be your wine
taster you guys will work as a team
fine but if he raises his voice once
once
i'm out please don't stick to that
policy april
the new parks interns start today and i
was wondering if you would deliver a
little welcome speech no
go away watermelon martinis exposed
brick
carrie russell's hair why did you just
say those weird things
on the advice of my therapist dr richard
nygard whenever i feel like yelling
i just take a deep breath and say three
great things about being alive
gross yes can you tell me where jennifer
is i convinced her to quit
ugh martha stewart's apron line my
tomato plants
oh god i'm out where's my emergency list
recently i've been feeling like i've
wasted the last 10 years of my life
and it all started with this internship
and i don't want those kids to make the
same mistake okay
april you spent the last 10 years doing
amazing things with this parks
department and learning from the
greatest teacher in this or any business
leslie freaking nope
you'd be a checkout girl at a gas
station if it wasn't for that internship
sweet potato pie unlikely animal friend
pairings jennifer love hewitt
why are you all in my office we are on
one last mission to help the people of
pawnee
craig can you sign the requisition form
and speed things up
you know craig when i first met you i
thought there is a man who loves his job
and then i thought oh wow he's intense
and then i thought oh no
he's insane that person is psychotic and
i need to call the police
yeah that's usually the way it goes
you